alors à l'époque j'ai des 13es mort
d'une personne qui vivait à montréal ah
ouais ouais donc on y j -pd
et donc ouais et du coup je faisais les
et les retours tout le week-end et c'est
ça mais c'est pas énorme ça c'était déjà
là bas ces dix heures d'avion ah oui 28
bat la chaque fois quoi bah oui tu crois
que j allais coman miss bala les retours
et cali tous les week end là bas j'ai vu
là-bas non parce qu'il m'a remercie
assez rapidement
non non
mais les canadiens ne baisse pas du tout
comme les français
ne court pas du tout mais alors qui sait
qu'il est différent alors pourquoi pas
ce que disent les rangs de vignes
alors comment je l'expliqué ce avec des
mots doux aux etats unis c'est pas comme
en france aux états unis par exemple
labatt mais on s'est empressé
d'expliquer
aux états unis par exemple si on n'est
pas tenu ensemble une fellation par
exemple à régler par dont vous nous avez
les mots c'est que c'est considérer
quelque chose d'extrêmement avancée dans
la relation intime un petit mot aussi
mais je suis français
grasset que d'envoyer des foules ça veut
dire l'omaha il est rond dans l'île
devait les l'année dans la rue voisine
on va diligenter à quatre pattes ont
baissé je connais pas la personne mais
pour toi là tu personnes il dit bonjour
voila c'est qu'en france tu vois on est
très préliminaires au départ et pour moi
fellation c'est aussi dans les
préliminaires mais en revanche parfois
l'acte l'acte sexuel en lui-même on le
met la deuxième fois parce que c'est
considéré comme très intrusif bas au
canada où était donné par les
sexuelle on peut y aller
des préliminaires les coûts n'a en
revanche
conduite à
voilà pourquoi parce que notamment avec
les préservatifs et tout ça il n'y a pas
de ya pas de contact
alors tu vois ce que je veux dire donc
quand t'as pas des codes au début tu
surprendre les gens ah oui ils sont
quand même bien voilà c'est vrai que si
vous souhaitez sur son physique comme un
mort de faim
mais c'est vrai comme la misère sur le
monde non c'est bon je reconnais quand
je connais que si tu dis tiens j'ai fait
j'ai fait ça cet acte là je rencontre
quelqu'un en boîte de nuit je lui ai
fait ça chez lui je suis rentré le
lendemain tu lis à une personne va être
choqué si bas six mois ci à massy ah oui
ça m'est jamais arrivé
de faire ça m'irait bien moi le moi ça
m'irait bien le canada le faire sans
préliminaires soupe c'est le mieux cran
à aa
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce que je vais dire j'étais
vraiment pris de court
ou qu'est ce que vous avez fait de fou
par aman j'ai perdu vingt kilos par
amour parce que je sortais avec une
fille qui me surnommer bill parce qu'une
fois que je ressemblais habile du bigdil
bâtiment et non mais vraiment et ça me
complexe et donc j'ai perdu vingt kilos
chaque sur un semi marathon et voilà
comme la torture est un et qu'on les ait
perdu ma vie en fait c'était mieux avant
vous et moi il ya un grand défi que je
met à danser déjà dans ma vie et je n'ai
jamais dit et quand j'ai fait de la
radio avec vous en 2011 j'étais tout le
temps dehors souvenez-vous pas jeter en
extérieur je suis jeune j'ai pas fait
une minute d'antenne autour de la table
oui le producteur de l'époque laurent
thibeault m'avait dit je ne peux pas te
mettre autour de la table avec cyril
parce que cyril c'est un monstre les
gens autour de la table ont de la
bouteille il faut vraiment que tu
envoies et si tu viens autour de la
table pour rien dire cyril va te tuer et
ça ne fonctionnera pas donc tu vas
rester dehors même s'il fait moins 4 tu
resteras dehors tu ne rentrera pas dans
dessus du rock vous avez désigné
d'humains
laurent tout ça c'est bon ça ne veut pas
ouais et je m'étais dit en défi un jour
je prouverai que je suis capable de
parler autour d'une table c'est vers la
radio et à la télé ou quelques possibles
ce n'est pas
[Applaudissements]
le truc que je vais bien je ne sais pas
pourquoi tu me dis que je suis un
monstre je veux vraiment super sympa et
bonne raison que j'annonce que je suis
sympa comment je vendais valérie
barre était vraiment adoré faire ça à
l'époque c'est vrai que je n'ai jamais
fait de radio
bordel apparemment vous avez fait des
trucs fous pareils quoi le plus c'est ce
que par amour par amour quand on aime
quelqu'un fait des trucs fous pas vendre
un jeu
l'instant j'ai pas tout timgad à marine
a fait un truc ça moi que j'avais
totalement oublié ah oui j'avais écrit
un bouquin pour un concours qui était
arrivé deuxième et mon mari en cachette
il l'a fait il a payé à prix d'auteur le
bouquin ça devrait mieux des maisons de
ses économies à l'épreuve mais quinze
jours après j'avais une demande d'audit
heures pour le publier
les belles histoires
j'aime les belles histoires de genre non
mais c'est vrai franchement ben
apparemment vous avez été cocu
mais c'est quoi mais c'est vrai j'ai eu
une longue discussion avec fatou ce
matin
fini le clip parce que à me normand mais
non au contraire pas comme son amant
vient s'installer chez vous
est
ce que vous savez qu'elle nous attendons
qu'elle regarde toutes vos éditions je
lève et hier elle nous a entendu parler
de l'infidélité féminine a elle a
entendu ma question sur un amant
n'est-il pas avantagés par rapport à
quelqu'un de routinier et donc ce matin
il m'a convoqué on m'a demandé qu'est ce
que c'est accepter soit plus à la
musique convoqué absolument rien à quoi
tu reçois un mail
c'est le soldat il est convoqué par sa
fausse mère bien j'ai lu à tout sans
rien men
alors attends merde 10h30 heure la chute
des géants elle avait les croissants ah
ouais bien sûr aller croissant ils ont
fini d odieux non mais on a eu une
longue discussion mais pourquoi cette
question qu'est ce que tu voulais dire
'est-ce que tu sous-entends bécaud et
maintenant c'est clair je peux vous
répondre et je suis très heureux de vous
le dire cyril elle n'a pas d'âme en a
l'accusé qui lui a dit pas tout dit elle
en tout cas fatou tu m'entraîner
vraiment bravo fatou bâtiment
extrêmement bien bravo ma fac toulouse
avait fait de pires depuis hier
se marier par amour ouais je suivais un
peu l'émission
j'ai affrété un avion
à s'arrêter un avis pourquoi ça arrive
pour que la fin à l'époque la femme
rejoignent sur le tournage là vous avez
affrété vous demandera bien un avion
falcon un truc général cône ouais
falcone avait privé quoi ce alcon un
salto non ma falcon à falcon on voit ça
coûtait cette connerie brooks ça c'est
très cher cesser au moins 25 millions
mais là en fait si vous avez vraiment
jeter votre argent dans les faits
totalement ces jeux vous appelez cas par
cas pas ses racines dans la vision
déconnecté des latérales aux intrusions
ou frais c'est ça voilà les musiciens
non mais c'est parce que c'est mignon
c'est qu'ils associent toujours faire
plaisir cadeaux générosité avec jean
louis basse d'écossé un cadeau dont ce
que tu fais ça comme des cacahuètes mais
comme antoine a eu quelque chose d'un
repas tout mais comment toi être
autonome un beau cadeau c'est quand tu
sais ce que l'autre attend pas les
montres à quelqu'un parce que tu aimes
les montes tu t'es fait plaisir à toi
merci donc moi par exemple je vous
racontais mes méthodes
[Applaudissements]
tu vois nos fruits ce n est pas mon cas
ne s'est pas mon cadeau idéal non mais
c'est voilà si je n'ai pas fait une
table très plaisir car vous conférant
plus que la wii alors oui au japonais
veut dire ça n'a rien à voir mais c'est
quand même
j'ai un très beau jeu je la sens pas
mais personne avec qui je partage ma vie
honnêtement sourire sûrement pas j'ai
pas dis
que je connais bien
c'est un mec là ben oui je sais
c'est une info médias sur le même bassin
dépend tu parle de gâchis
saluer celui du monde du marteau quoi
vous
comme ça c'est à la télé
une émission de radio
quand tu peux que lui qui
peut expliquer les raisins secs
se raconte emma ah oui je croyais que tu
étais ricains et parce que tu les pentes
de ses raisins secs
je suis un amateur de fruits secs les
surcoûts et compliqué à gérer
oui alors dit la personne la personne
par nombre adore ça la cuisine ah oui tu
vois à doha doha de biens est en fête
géniale cette personne avait flashé sur
une cocotte j'avais d'une grande marque
tu sais tu vois la grand'mare tient
comme ça pendant mille ans et tout ça et
moi tu m'offres une cocotte faire la
cuisine mais la gemballa tu vois ça vaut
un petit peu gens c'est god j'ai senti
que j'ai offert la
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
che cette marque là qu ait connu si je
suis rentré j'ai discuté cocotte g koné
arrive on se met un poulet entier de
dans
le petit
voilà à l'émission late on l'attend sur
et j'ai offert ce cadeau d'un but que
j'ai mais j'avais remarqué ce que
l'abonné basket loti
dabakala bafoulabé il attention ils
étaient en train de prendre son pouls et
la tension avait travaillé un temps
social
dirais qu'on a on n'a rien eu c'est au
tour nable internet attention j'ai pris
ma tension jemappes ag2050 ont fait des
pertes en soit j'ai tout compris non
mais exemple il dit n'importe quoi mais
aussi une femme te dit chérie j'ai envie
de te voir pas alors toi maman qui a
plus d'avion qu'à cela ne tienne je vais
réserver un avion maintenant eh ben
c'est une attention pour aider d'abrutis
il est l'un des compagnons
c'est quoi cette ville-etat co2 pour il
a
mieux fait d'y envoyer une cocotte
[Applaudissements]